merci la pole et au président christian
jacob merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
savez vous ce qu'est un sentiment
d'abaissement et d'humiliation qui
résulte d'une atteinte à l'honneur et à
la dignité
ce sentiment c'est la définition de la
honte
cette honte que vous dit ressentir à
l'égard du président de la république
imaginez une seconde
monsieur le premier ministre que j'ai
osé évoquer comme tous les français
les prouve cette honte qu'inspirent les
comportements du président de la
république vous vous seriez drapé dans
votre vertu invoquant le manque de
respect de la fonction présidentielle
les attaques personnelles et indigne à
l'égard du président de la république
française
un débat et une opposition qui ne
seraient pas à la hauteur mais ce qui
n'est pas à la hauteur monsieur le
premier ministre
ce sont les comportements léger
inquiétants et dangereux d'un président
narcisse qui s'est noyé dans un torrent
de confidences qui ont abîmé la fonction
présidentielle et sa propre image
ce qui n'est pas à la hauteur c'est un
président qui dévoile des opérations
classés secret défense y compris des
attentats ciblés
ce qui n'est pas à la hauteur c'est le
spectacle sans précédent d'un premier
ministre qui a honte du président qui
l'a nommé la question que l'on doit vous
poser à ce stade est simple monsieur le
premier ministre
n'avez vous pas vous même honte tête
encore le chef du gouvernement de
françois hollande
car si vous pensez réellement ce que
vous avez dit vous auriez dû
démissionner c'est le minimum de
cohérence que l'on attend d'un homme
politique qui se revendique de ne pas se
taire et de nommer les choses mais pour
cela monsieur le premier ministre il ne
s'agit pas de faire des phrases il faut
avoir du courage et une fois de plus je
crains que vous ne soyez plus fort dans
le verbe que dans l'action
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls le président
monsieur le président jacques home c'est
vrai que nous sommes un rendez vous
important qui s'ouvre celui qui va
compter pour le destin du pays
l'élection présidentielle votre famille
politique est d'ailleurs en train de
préparer ce rendez vous et c'est
l'occasion en effet à la fois de faire
le bilan de comparer et puis d'ouvrir
des perspectives de faire le bilan et
nous avons déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
en l'ordre ces derniers jours la semaine
dernière sur la politique économique sur
les chiffres du chômage même s'il faut
rester modeste sur ce sujet là enfin ce
sont 90 il vous plaît s'il vous plaît -
de l'oeil le début de l'année c'est
l'occasion de faire le point
la première partie de la loi de finances
a été votée sur les baisses d'impôt
concernant les classes moyennes et les
couches populaires
le plfss va être votée donc c'est
l'occasion de rappeler parce que nous
avons travaillé avec la majorité sur
cette mesure qui concerne les retraités
et la cgc l'occasion de dire qu' un état
fort un état qui digne de ce nom est
capable d'évacuer dans des conditions de
dignité d'humanité en étant de fermeté
lalinde la jungle de calais c'est
l'occasion encore une fois de dire face
au malaise des policiers
ce que nous avons fait en faveur de la
police et de la gendarmerie parce que
vous vouliez pas fait et puisque vous
pouvez inviter
c'est l'occasion aussi monsieur le
président et moi je le fais
régulièrement ici dans les médias y
compris dans des réunions publiques
d'affirmer monsieur jacob parce que moi
j'ai aucun problème affirmé la fierté
qui a été la nôtre quand le président de
la république a décidé d'envoyer nos
armées pour sauver le mali c'est de
saluer l'action qui a été celle de la
france quand il a fallu sauver la grèce
qui étaient menacés de sortie de l'eau
oh c'est de saluer nous allons le
célébrer bientôt à la coff 22 à
marrakech quelle a été l'action de la
france de sa diplomatie pour un rendez
vous essentiel pour l'avenir de la
planète ces 2 sec quelle a été
l'attitude du président de la république
et le tous les responsables politiques
face au terrorisme
moi monsieur jacob contrairement à vous
je n'ai aucun problème pour assumer ce
que nous avons fait depuis 2012
il ya eu bien sûr des erreurs il ya eu
bien sûr des problèmes mais d'assumer
cette fierté
et puis monsieur jacob c'est l'occasion
aussi de comparer puisque vous êtes en
plein débat et qui va y avoir encore un
débat des candidats à la primaire de la
droite demain c'est de dire tout
simplement quel est le programme de la
droite supprimer l isf supprimé trois
cent mille ou à 700 mille fonctionnaires
selon les programmes
c'est le ramener la retraite à 65 ans ce
qui veut dire concrètement un départ à
la retraite pour ceux à 70 ans quand on
souhaiterait une retraite à taux plein
voilà quelle doit être la nature du
débat
et puis ouvrir aussi bien sur un certain
nombre de personnages je me nomme
monsieur jacob moi je vous réponds je
pense que dans dans ce moment là dans ce
moment là où le pays est toujours sous
la menace du terrorisme dans ce moment
là où nous connaissons toujours un
chômage de masse dans ce moment là où il
y a tellement de doute tellement de
doutes sur la parole publique et le
débat qui est en train de se dérouler et
les attaques par exemple à l'égard de
françois bayrou ne rehausse pas me
semble-t-il le débat v mais à chaque
fois
donc monsieur jacob au lieu de rigoler
au lieu du rigolet au lieu d'interpeller
au lieu de mettre en cause
moi à ma place comme chef du
gouvernement je souhaite tout simplement
qu'il est de la dignité et que le
problème des responsables publics quel
qu'il soit c'est de redonner de la
fierté et de l'espérance
je vous laisse à vos sarcasmes moi je
n'ai qu'une seule boussole
la france et la gauche la gauche la
france parce que je ne peux pas que vous
vous arriviez au pouvoir
ce que je pense que nous pouvons
prolonger ce quinquennat et parce que ce
dont les français ont besoin celles
retrouvées oui de l'espoir parce que
c'est ce que nous devons au pays et ce
n'est pas vous qui pourrait le proposer
merci monsieur le premier ministre par
les hommes